I just learned you can set a Google
Alert to your own name and Google will
email you all the cool things that other
people with your name are doing is it
Joe Zimmerman javelin thrower who is
killing it right now there's an actor
has been in a bunch of movies we're very
proud of that jay-z I went on to
LinkedIn think of there might be like 20
others there were 400 and their doctors
lawyers CEOs it made me realize I don't
know if I would make the Forbes 400
wealthiest Joe Zimmerman's trying to
make a name for myself can't even make a
name for myself just among people named
me a mad at Google right now I had an
important question to ask and I remember
typing in what is my before I could
finish the thing that Google suggested
was spirit animal
and I was like yeah what is it cuz you
see other people and you know right
you're like - can but nobody's ever told
me mine so I'm genuinely taking this
online spirit animal quiz hope and I'm a
chocolate lab I don't know if I've ever
been more disappointed than to learn I'm
a crow I thought these were supposed to
be fun
Congrats you're the scavenger bird
you're defensive you're defensive the
crow likes laughing and eating everybody
likes laughing an idiot
it's almost like these internet quizzes
are just making stuff up I was
aggravated like a crow would be so I'm
back to Google looked up second opinion
online spirit animal quiz like no way
I'm a crow twice this time I'm basically
lying trying to get chocolate lab love
snuggling and being rescued come on
quiz number two
told me I'm a cricket that's not even an
animal that's an insect I don't want a
spirit bug so now crows starting to
sound pretty good now I'm researching
more about crows to learn a little bit
more about my people type it into Google
are crows cool and short version they
are they are cool I recommend them crows
recognize individual human faces I know
you guys like this guy's not gonna keep
talking about crows I kind of need to
I'll sum up the study real quick
basically a scientist was mean to a crow
and then released it waited to see if
the crow remembered him not only did it
remember him but it was like I hate you
and then it surprised him when it told
other crows and it could point him out
in a crowd it was like that dude's cool
that dude's cool that's the dude and
then those crows spread the word to even
more crows they're like that's the man
who bullied Jonathan
that doesn't sound it doesn't sound that
crazy because we also recognize other
human faces that be the equivalent of us
recognizing an individual crows face
like there he is that's the one who
stole my windowsill pie so don't mess
with crows because they're smart they
hold grudges and groups of crows are
called murders
you know and groups of people are called
groups I'll tell you else holds a grudge
crow Zimmerman now I got a grudge
against Google because I still can't
remember my original question
Google is amazing but the suggestions
are too distracting how to lose weight
is that what you're gonna ask
now hold on I got this I was gonna ask
how to make money fast
that's what other people are asking no
wait how fast
so now I'm donating plasma
you